und jetzt gerade wo ich diese 77 gerade
ärzte 65
[Musik]
ich glaube ich bin der einzige der so
excited ist freundlich jetzt gerade sind
die neuen klamotten gelaunten luca job
also unter anderem dieses t shirt hier
noch zwei modi ist noch ein weiteres t
shirt schlüsselanhänger in der reflektor
jacke jeans jacke also links in der
beschreibung oder hier nochmal die url
kommen statt punkte aber jetzt fangen
wir an mit dem video wir befinden uns
nämlich heute auf der website google
führt keine ahnung wie das ausgesprochen
wird auf jeden fall kann man hier eine
kategorie auswählen das heißt sie sagen
jetzt beispielsweise mal einfach kalt
schauen jetzt sagt diese website uns
hast google auto komplett discrete war
griff wie auf und dann müssen wir da ein
geben was wir denken was danach wohl
kommen könnte ich würde mal einfach
hitler eingeben
man hat übrigens nur drei leben was sind
denn so die bekanntesten personen der
welt war griff wie oft keine ahnung was
können dann einmal eingeben obama auch
nicht bei christoph trump auf barack
obama donald trump cool dass ich dafür
dann keine punkte bekomme ich will noch
mal eine neue runde in richtung kalkar
entschied kurz vor ns mario platz sechs
also 5000 punkte habe ich schon mal also
es ist eine konsole von nintendo an alle
unter euch die sich mit gaming mich
auskenne cheat codes von nds mario kart
vielleicht nimmt kurz vor ns zelda
eventuell ja ist auf jeden fall mit
dabei
begabt puppe und nicht verdammt ich habe
keine ahnung was ich jetzt auf ein geben
könnte ich gebe mal noch joschi 1 gab es
aber auch nicht es gibt noch eine
s-klasse games dass ich da nicht drauf
gekommen bin und sonst stehen nur noch
ein paar andere spiele metroid oh mein
gott klar dass ich auch drauf kommen
können ich will noch ein letztes mal
culture probieren keilförmigen culcha
candela movie about müssen wir
kompletten dh ich gebe mal einen wie
lance
ich gucke mir voll gern filme über
flugzeuge an movie about us
wo wir bau traf das sucht ca jedes
mädchen mindestens 4000 mal in ihrem
leben movie about that eventuell tsunami
mcdonald's movie about time obama food
facebook drama
ein film über schlagzeuger black women
at nasa
ich frage mich mittlerweile gar nichts
mehr jetzt nehmen wir als kategorie
einfach mal people picture software
donald trump kann man immer ein geben am
platz sechs liegt es auf hohem niveau
es gibt doch locker gegen solche
perversen wieder suchen
zoom
nicht um in der tat pictures auf
marshmallow eventuell weil von dem ich
dachte weil von dem er das gesicht nicht
offiziell bekannt ist bed bugs dogs
papis
und ich denke an personen müssen euch
vorstellen kategorie heißt people und
dann kommen als auswahlmöglichkeiten an
nahezu nur tiere
saint-flour eventuell sogar auf platz
vier so gut haben wir noch nie gekriegt
im hau to draw
damit ich dachte das wäre richtig
otto groll face eventuell nie im haut
was wird denn oft gemalt sagen wir mal
landscape york
ja wir haben hier doch rost happy
christmas tree dragons hotspur
snowflakes wieder die hälfte eigentlich
notiere ein to head to have sex with it
to go zudem weil man sich beim touran to
be loved the world work out of work out
ist doch genau das gleiche wie goethe
bildschirm und bieten oft und gerne girl
für das eigentlich genau das gleiche
video have sex aber okay am bier hipster
wieso muss man um hipster zu sein denn
sein team macht überhaupt keinen sinn
transition ride my boyfriend
ticker in love with eventuell auch nicht
ich werde richtig gut in diesem spiel
sitting on my mom das ist genau das was
ich auch ein gebe nur anders formuliert
dem feeling auf eventuelle neue feeling
of being that
auf platz eins live feeling of being in
relation ist auf being in love schreibe
ich mal air feeling auf bin single
das leider nicht ich habe noch einen
versuch ein lasso feeling of being
kamine shop.de effekt nennt wow ist in
der big city und der city
ich hasse so was eigentlich das nächste
was wir vollenden müssen ist how to look
in die preis es gibt ja wirklich leute
die haben nicht so richtig in die augen
gucken können halten eventuell nie im
hauttyp 38 verdammt daran habe ich gar
nicht gedacht du lac heißt der
einerseits see hin mit den augen auf
englisch aber andererseits heißt es auch
haute rücktritt zum beispiel wie schaffe
ich jetzt gut auszusehen also für andere
auszusehen und das ist das einzige was
sie kamen als nächstes würde ich sagen
nämlich immer die kategorien namen
melaine walker würde ich sagen allen
walker ist auf jeden fall auf den 10
alan miller allen chipmunks chipmunk nie
die kenne ich tatsächlich alle nicht aus
allen walker keith richards eventuell ja
genau den gips ergibt walker gibt's
nicht kippen müller gibt es auch nicht
gibt es mit gibt es auch nicht dass ein
typischer englischen namen
ich auch wieder alle nicht james bond
auf jeden fall
james jordan gibt es auch
james bond 007 james franco stimmt er im
pool kenne ich noch von breaking bad
der ist auf platz vier aber mehr in kenn
ich nicht also ich gehe wieder eine erin
muller wahrscheinlich auch nicht allen
smith 17
wieso denke ich denn noch an allen nun
würde ich aber sagen wir mal die
kategorie questions im haus zu holen
also holt in worte was fast drei sachen
so einfach nur ausscheidungen hier ist
noch kotze einen lachen tränen happy
meals monschauer eventuell know how long
to have sex and the city
sleep so lange es geht alter the new
york new york
was ich bin so scheiße in diesem spiel
schreibt hier ist mein los ist auf platz
zwei er ist auf platz eins mayrleb ist
nicht lips habe das
das heißt den bauchnabel bellybutton
heißt auf 19 email einig heißt es dann
nn email weil das ja ein lokales am
kanal biel gern eventuell kein bier bei
wow modeln
ich habe gar nicht mehr an berufe
gedacht model doktor male model surgeon
lawyers bei foster parent oder
resistance of the states
keine ahnung wer das sein will anders
stelle mich dass heute gewählt
allerdings auch werden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat mir
einen like dadurch das ganze nochmal
schöner da gibt's wirklich unzählige
versionen unzählige fragen also wenn ich
noch mal spielen soll freunde 50.000
likes ich weiß es ist eine große summe
50.000 likes dann spielt das ganze spiel
nochmal wie zu beginn schon gesagt die
neuen klamotten sind jetzt in meinem
shop online also top-adresse und in der
beschreibung eingeblendet ich würde mich
freuen wenn einfach mal vorbeischauen
wenn man sehr viel mühe gegeben bei den
designs von den klamotten aber auch
sowie der neue shop aussieht also haben
eine komplett andere schriftart jetzt
genommen andere text ich habe jetzt ein
zitat oben mit drin
wir haben das ganze interface bearbeitet
wir haben neues shopsystem was uns sehr
sehr sehr sehr viel geld kostet ist aber
auch egal schaut einfach mal vorbei ihr
müsst ihr nichts kaufen ich würde
einfach nur freuen wenn ihr euch ganz
einfach mal anschaut und ja trotzdem bin
ich leider immer noch eine nummer
kleiner vollidiot